when issue 75 of Sandman was done there
was one big story that I plotted and
never told it was a whole storyline you
never you never knew about
I talked with DC Comics about doing it
but their business department at that
point wasn't prepared to talk to me
about doing
Sandman on essentially any other terms
and the ones that I signed up when I
signed my contract to Sandman in 1987
you know I've always been a band and
worked on an assumption they've made a
lot of sense to me the way I ran my
career in the way I'd ran The Dresden
Dolls didn't feel like this sheisty
strategic play to like social network
and get close to our fans so that we
could make a lot of money we just did
that because that's what we liked doing
like you spend enough time with your
fans and they really know you and they
really like you and they really trust
you and this sort of thing doesn't seem
strange it seems very possible but then
from the outside if you haven't been
following the plot it looks like this
kind of crazy phenomenon so trying to
explain to someone in a few sentences
how I've spent the last 13 years of my
life and how I've connected with every
fan and been very very very close in a
real way with my fan base it's kind of
hard to explain because it's a long
story but none of this is surprising to
me and it's not really surprising to
people around me either there's like
this perfect alchemy of things happening
where I got released from my label I
knew I had this great record in me
because I knew I'd written all the songs
I did have it in my head finished in a
specific kind of way like there was this
sound I wanted and when you hear the
record you kind of get it and you
understand I think this album is the
most personal and intimate and also the
most poppy and mainstream record I've
ever made so the fact that I got the
album
I had been dreaming about and the fact
this was really my first big independent
release happening at the same time it
was great I wouldn't have put this album
out until it was fantastic and I think
actually I did wait I had to wait until
I had everything lined up and perfect I
had to have something that I was
obscenely proud of before I could go to
the whole fan base and say okay this is
it this is my first big one that I'm
doing myself everyone coming home I'm
I'm building and constantly getting more
and more connected with the people who
are coming with the fans and Michael
who's the drummer and also the tour
director and I are really excited to
find like where we can push the
boundaries of things that haven't been
done before in terms of what the
audience brings to the show and that
means like including technology and the
stuff that we're talking about with the
MIT Media Lab and you know really saying
like okay we know you guys are game for
it do this send us this bring this and
when you come to this show you're going
to see all of these things manifested in
a way you never could have imagined so
we're really actually trying to make
every city and every show totally unique
to the people who are coming let's see I
tend to think that you know what you do
is one giant interconnected piece of
performance art called Amanda Palmer
which includes
paintings you know getting a bunch of
artists and paintings and demanding
partly that's painted in Amanda Palmer
tweets and ativan makes an album it all
sort of ties in but it's all about
connection and it's all about connecting
to other human beings
the thing that's been weirdest for me
was when I was writing Sandman I thought
it was very very transient I thought it
was disposable for me the joy of comics
was the idea I'm working in a disposable
medium I'm working a monthly medium I
didn't actually think that when I began
it this stuff was going to be around if
you told me that 25 years from now
Sandman would be in print all 11 12 13
volumes whatever you wanted would be in
print and they'd be collecting these
huge heavy absolute editions as well and
they would have sold all these millions
of copies I think I would have thought
you were crazy but what's actually
happened is watching generation after
generation come in to Sandman now I
realize I'm signing books for people who
were not born once a my number one came
out I'm signing books for people who are
in signing lines with their kids who
weren't born when salmon number one came
out a year ago I was seeing online
people saying and I have to go and check
out Doctor Who because I know Neil has
written an episode I was gonna that's
kind of nice some you know people see it
know who I am what I get now is people
I've never encountered before who have
never read anything else that I've
written just coming up to me and saying
bye-bye I just love the doctor's wife my
favorite episode of Doctor Who thank you
for writing it and and I say you're
welcome and just vaguely hope I'll pick
up something else out of everything
why started writing Sandman I was 26 I
was um I had no idea if this was going
to work or not I had this idea in my
head all I cared about was the joy of
getting to the next page the next panel
the next word the idea that that I had
all these cool stories in my head and I
hoped we wouldn't get cancelled before I
told them so that was really my agenda
when I was 26 well I get the story out
now there's part of me that goes you
know everything I'm writing I'm
imagining a hypercritical audience of
rough
fifteen million people looking over my
shoulder sterilized what Simon but then
I think you know the great thing about
Sandman is from the moment that I
discovered the internet and that people
were talking about Sandman on the
internet which would have been like rec
arts Comics DC circa 1989 end of 89 what
people were saying then never changed
for the next seven years of comics all
they ever said was it's not as good as
it used to be and the earlier stuff was
always whatever somebody had picked up
first and loved and and it carried on
with people talking about when Sandman
was good all the way through to 75
that's the thing no it's fine it's just
it's it's people and it's human nature
and the funny thing is now nobody knows
that now people pick up the graphic
novel books and they have favorites you
know they might like season of mists or
game of you or brief lives whatever kind
of the kindly ones which people hated
when it came out as a comic and now it
gets the best reviews of all um so I
take a long-term view on this I almost
don't care what people say when it comes
out when issue 75 of Sandman was done
and the story was laid to rest there was
one big story that I plotted
I never told because it didn't really
fit anywhere and it was a story that in
my head I called Sandman zero and it was
just what happened just before
Sandman one started there was a whole
storyline that you never you never knew
about it happens in 1914 1915
I talked with DC Comics about doing it
you know seven years ago for the the
20th anniversary of Sam
we better dat about of it but their
business department at that point wasn't
prepared to talk to me about doing
Sandman on essentially any other terms
and the ones that I signed up when I
signed my contract to Sandman in 1987
and the moment that new people were
running these economics the first thing
they did was come back to me and say
okay Sandman's 25th anniversary could we
do that thing you were talking about for
the 20th and I said sure it's just been
announced and it made headlines all
around the world that I've signed a five
book deal with HarperCollins so in terms
of books that are in the contract I've
got a book coming out called Tuesday
which is a little book about a panda
called Shu who sneezes and we wanted to
sort things out so that I could write
the sequels so those are in the contract
a book called fortunately the milk which
is a really goofy very very silly book
about the imagination and then I want to
do a sequel to autumn the frost giants
and I've started the sequel and it's all
plotted and then there's one more book
in the contract which is just whatever
the next children's book I write happens
to be I think people are going to be
going how how is he doing it how is he
doing it all look at him something new
every week without me actually sort of
going actually it's like four years
worth of work it's all happening to come
out around now which i think is what's
probably going to happen it sounds
incredibly impressive but all that five
books three are actually already written
and and two one is plotted and begun one
is just sitting there out in space
you